Velocity, the third v, is about the speed at which the data
arrives, ready to be processed. We need to be able to accept
and store that data, even when it's coming in at a rate
of terabytes per day. If we can't store it as it arrives,
we'll end up discarding some of it, and that's what we want
to avoid. Think about an ecommerce website. If we knew what products
you've looked at in the past, we can recommend similar products the
next time you visit our site. If you've had spent five minutes
looking at a particular item, we could maybe send you
an email informing you the product is on sale. If
we know that you typically browse our site using a
first generation iPad, we could suggest the latest model. This is
a huge difference to what we could do before, when
we only stored the records of the actual purchases. If we
can store and process all of our web server logs,
along with the purchase data that's in our traditional data warehouse.
We could give the customer a much better
shopping experience. Which would directly translate into bigger profits.
Yet another example is a movie site like Netflix.
Based on what they know about your viewing habits,
they can recommend movies to you. As you can
see here, because of what Ian's rated highly before,
this movie is recommend to him. And they can
even predict what rating he would give this movie.